you
you
hi my name is alex i'm a freelance web
developer here in Berlin and first off
thanks to the jas comforting for having
me here this is my first really properly
big audience and it's a great honor to
be here and thanks to all of you for
your interest in time so a brief
disclaimer before we start I as she just
said I work on a Novak in project called
hoodie hoodie and so this whole topic is
very close to my heart and the few code
examples I do have actually come from
hoodie but there's going to be very
little code and it's not going to be
self-promotional in any way so don't
worry about it so what I'm talking about
is this no back-end idea a new paradigm
in front and web development which some
are calling no back end which includes
the idea of having a back-end as a
service and essentially what it boils
down to is that you can build a
full-featured data-driven web
application on the browser side and not
worry what goes on on the server now I
don't know about you but to me this
sounds very desirable I'm primarily a
front-end developer but in practice of
course I'm not I'm both end developer as
probably many of you are because we
don't really have any choice at some
point ninety five percent of everything
I build requires some sort of data
storage or user authentication and so I
can either just slog through and build a
back-end I can hire bribe coerce or
somehow otherwise convince someone to
build it for me or I can just give up
and do something else so if this is a
big commercial thing you're probably not
going to have to worry about this
because somebody else is paying for
number two but if you just prototyping
an idea or if you're building something
that solves a small personal problem or
for just small products in general
option number two is often out of scope
and option number three is depressing so
you're probably going to try and do it
yourself and then you'll be looking at
this so I can sit down and I can deal
with all that I mean I can work with
these things but at the same time these
are all jobs other people's jobs
thankfully they make a living with this
and they know it really well and while i
can use PHP and rails and find a service
that framework and set up a database and
all that i could probably hack something
together that work
but it wouldn't be very good it would
take me too long and most importantly I
just don't want to it's not my job it's
not my expertise I probably wouldn't
enjoy it and I would probably find a way
to make terrible security mistakes so
really what do I need I mean in most
cases my requirements and indeed most
people's requirements at a basic level
are relatively simple what you want is
you want to have users so they can sign
in sign out and do user stuff you want
to be able to administer them and send
the new passwords when something goes
wrong you want to let them save and load
data because otherwise what's the point
you want to let them share the data with
each other or with the public maybe send
an email or two and ideally even let
them pay me for it that's not
particularly outlandish people have been
doing this for a very long time it's so
unspectacular I'd actually go and call
it boring it's not exactly particle
physics because this is particle physics
and particle physics is dictated by the
real world the web is not it is dictated
by what people think how it should work
so this stuff I think it shouldn't be
difficult I think it only should take a
couple of minutes so we're used to doing
stuff like this in the Dom you know just
manipulating the element is very query
so why can't signing up a user be
similarly simple why can't we just go
and do that so that's where the note
back end idea comes soon basically makes
that possible it's essentially about
delegation it turns something that is
difficult and full of pitfalls into a
commodity where the tricky and or dull
bits are handled by other people who are
better at it than you are and this makes
sense because we do it all the time in
all aspects of life so I doubt let any
of you do they're distributed version
control by themselves most of us go here
when something goes wrong with our
plumbing we call the plumber and when
something goes wrong with other dirty
things we call a lawyer so why can't we
do this with backends backends are hard
they're made up of a lot of different
components that will have to interact
with each other there's a variety of
languages and
in tax and even the simplest set up
there are arcane conventions that go
back 30 years and layers and layers of
choose compounded weirdness that really
takes ages to wrap my head around and
that's before you get a single user and
start scaling and really that sounds
like the first thing I want to get rid
of and you can get rid of it so by now
there are architectures and services
that more or less let you forget about
the backend and let you build these
complete data-driven web applications
from the client side all in jas and some
of them have really nifty features like
real-time data binding or offline
capabilities so what they do is they
turn your black your back-end into a
black box with an API so no back-end is
really a bit of a misnomer of course
there's a back-end you have to put the
stuff somewhere but it's not something
you have to worry about if you don't
want to ok so my three lines of code
examples I just showed you this a minute
ago actually I didn't show you exactly
that but very nearly that so that's no
back-end code it runs in the front end
and it does exactly like what it looks
like it does you can do that a few
seconds after you've scaffold about your
project in whatever no back in service
is you're using and that's a real thing
that's code from hoodie you can use that
day and it creates a proper user account
it authenticates that user and then you
can start storing data and storing data
doesn't look too different I mean
there's a store object it has an ADD
method and you give it data and it's
just a type and Jason and you'll notice
that there's no setting up database
there are no schemas there is no config
if you want to store data you store data
go ahead the infrastructure gets out of
your way want to send a multi-part email
from the browser go ahead in 2013 you
can send a multi-part email from the
browser why the hell not so that's a
nice example of the know back in
philosophy it's all about the API it's a
front-end centric the actual
implementation of sending that email
might be complicated it might not be
complicated why should we care it's
sending an email it's not that
interesting it should just be a thing
that you call and then it works so just
to wrap all that up no back end is
essentially a design paradigm for
architectures and frameworks that
abstracts complex back-end operations
and technology into a simple to use rest
api and as i said there is a back-end
but you don't have to deal with it if
you don't want to and of course most of
these services are extensible so you can
add functionality with plugins or
packages so that all sounds pretty good
and I think you get the idea and that's
all the code you're going to see from
you today so what I really want to talk
about is why this is cool and then what
I really want to talk about is why it's
important so what's cool is it makes web
development simple and accessible so all
of these things oh sorry for just a
second all of these solutions typically
typically come either as a service
that's hosted somewhere or as an
installable package that just includes
everything you run it and you get your
server your database you just get all of
it and that's very quick setup it's very
easy and it's a very low barrier to
entry in essence you download a thing
you double-click it and you've got a
development environment that's very
convenient so ideally and this is for
example the case in hoodie where you
used to have a text back with multiple
languages and data formats and maybe
even several databases and query
language and server configurations you
now have one language JavaScript all the
way through and you have one day to
format Jason all the way through it
doesn't matter where you access it
everything is JavaScript and Jason
that's really nice even the config files
are Jason which is cool and you often
get very simple built-in deployment
mechanisms this go so far that sometimes
it's simply just a button in a web
interface that says deploy and then you
click it and it's deployed and that is
one that's a wonderful user experience
for a developer really so everything's
really really quick to get going and in
general speed is great factor because
there's very little confident
boilerplate you can start doing
substantial things almost immediately
there's nothing standing in the way of
your ideas and
testing problems of your app which is
what the user does with your app you can
just go that's very nice and as I said
most of these solutions have additional
perks like offline mode or live sync
between devices or this nice reactive
use thing which is actually called um
you know the live data binding if
something gets changed in one uses view
all the other connected users get that
immediately and the cool thing is that's
not something you have to invoke in
those cases it's just automatically the
baseline of how these things work so you
save ages not implementing that yourself
so that of course lends itself to rapid
prototyping because you can build these
things and you can turn them out so
quickly that you can just use real data
real behaviors and give your test users
real devices you don't have to muck
about with cards or dummies or something
it's so fast you can actually build real
working prototypes with this well let's
get back to that first point with focus
you start developing in the browser near
the user where the unique aspects of
your app are so you build the user
facing features quickly you validate or
dismiss them you experiment you pivot at
will and you don't have to worry about
the infrastructure setting it up or I
was configured or anything you can just
go and find out whether the idea is
actually worth spending time on without
spending a lot of time on the
infrastructure now back end solutions
bring some interesting aspects in with
regard to flexibility so many of these
let you host let you host wherever you
like as they should but since they're so
easy to install that could also mean you
just have a box that sits in the corner
of your office and there you can have
auto updating self hosted and secure
device independent and deploy software
just running on a box in the corner of
your office and it's just as easy to
install as the development environment
and that's actually becoming a popular
idea right now so here's a nice quote we
spent so much time on the internet that
we should all have a own digital a home
on
line so far we're only guessing a couple
of gigantic hotels and he's right and no
back-end can provide a nice vector to
get away from that what I can also do is
if we can agree on some sort of
convention backends become swappable
commodities because all you have talked
to is the API and if the api's are the
same across various backends you can
just switch in the will you can use a
local one some something you host
yourself something that's hosted by a
commercial service it's easy to switch
what goes on behind it is important but
no back-end offers some new approaches
to old problems as well in my favorite
one by far is the idea of having one
back-end per user so you as a developer
build your app a static HTML hosted on
github page for example and each user
hosts their own data themselves on
dropbox and google drive with remote
storage or whatever and there's plenty
of application business models that lend
themselves to this type of architecture
namely those where the users don't share
stuff that much and this has a couple of
great advantages sorry first of all
scales really easily because you don't
have the data secondary data privacy is
easier to guarantee because again you
don't have the data and the other cool
thing is multiple apps can access or
could access the same users you data
stores so much like something like a
Google Calendar we have to muck about
with caldas and all sorts of things you
could have that in a more easier way
with Anna back end down so each user
could have only one calendar one address
book want to do list but different apps
talk to them and they own the data it's
on their servers but the server's expose
an API to the apps so I think all this
sounds pretty cool I think it
potentially brings a large increase in
simplicity and comfort into the work we
do but for me that's coincidental really
it's not the underlying point the point
where I think this gets valuable is that
I
the internet is unwell and no back-end
could help so let's go back in time for
a second most of you probably know what
this is this is the ARPANET at some
point in the past i think the 80s no
1977 okay the idea of the ARPANET was
connect geographically distributed
computing resources because computing
was expensive and well it just makes
sense to connect them forget about all
the new king stuff but it was important
that the connections be reliable because
the equipment was crap back then it was
all bespoke and kept breaking and the
telephone lines or whatever how they
connected them were also terrible and so
we got packet switching on tcp/ip and we
also got this mental image of the
distributed network now on a technical
level that still accurate of course
that's how the web works more or less in
practice though the individual the
individual nodes are not of equal size
and importance so this is more what the
internet actually looks like in terms of
traffic so the big ones are exactly what
you expect the biggest one is google com
many of the smaller big ones are also
Google and the second big one is
facebook yahoo and apple and stuff like
that so lots of traffic goes through
relatively few relatively large nodes
and this means in the classical sense of
a distributed network that they Apple
significant points of failure
potentially not necessarily in this
reliability sense that they had back in
the 70s in that they'd just stop routing
the packets around and everything would
break but in a more general security
sense so if an antagonistic third party
can access anyone's data in one of those
nodes they must be considered broken and
as we know this is the case so ideally
the web even the social web is properly
distributed to avoid these kinds of
things in the future and our Tim
berners-lee what's it like this he says
we must make what I call social machines
y equals and that I have no idea in
which people can collaborate together
but do so anyway that's decentralized
not based on a central hub and that's so
terribly obvious I feel bad
putting it up there because I think we
can all agree on that but how would it
work so here's an interesting idea this
guy dreams of a future where everybody
has their own server just not the way
you think of it you know a rack
somewhere but it could be your computer
at home a little box next to your TV a
gaming console small server somewhere in
the data center maybe it's not important
it will be like having a mobile phone in
fact it might even be your mobile phone
because it's connected all the time
anyway and you're not going to get that
much traffic on it so your own server
would be so easy to use and easily
integrated with your existing devices
that even your granny would have one so
that's a nice dream but intrinsically no
back-end technology can be really
helpful here because it can help
redistribute apps and user data away
from central nodes and large single
points of failure and it can decrease
the number of data silos which don't
talk to each other and people always
complain about and it can through this
enhanced data security and sovereignty
and what can also do is provide more
infrastructural independence from these
large compromised services with their
own agendas by China back ends into
commodities but it can also do because
of the low barrier to entry is empower
people to build and or run their own
localized tools and solve their own
problems and i also think was really
cool as it brings together the best part
of browser based applications and
locally installed software so
browser-based is cool because it's
browser based you can run it on anything
that can open a browser that's a huge
advantage but you can also have it
running locally and storing your data
locally and not talking to anyone if you
you're concerned about security
implications so that's what pretty neat
but crucial problem is all this
self-hosting the app developing the one
back end per user it has to compete with
the incredibly polished products of
enormous companies so at any given
moment Facebook is looking for at least
three UX people and they already have I
don't know I mean quite a few so these
ideas have to compete on the levels of
functionality user experience design
critical user masses always a big
problem and convene
all of which are perceived is more
important than security which fits in
well with one of the talks we had
earlier security is not perceived easily
or that well so this whole idea is a bit
of a hard sell and we're not going to
get there but continuing to build stuff
by nerds for nerds we've got to make it
easy convincing and enjoyable to move a
personal data away from the big players
it has to be as enticing as leaving my
space so we need great self hosted
applications which we can use to manage
our emails personal pictures and all the
other stuff incidentally he's on next I
didn't even know that until today but
what this means in the end is that we
have to build better tools simpler tools
that make this kind of computing more
accessible and this is our job as j/s
people because the browser is not only a
document viewer anymore it's becoming
the world's most advanced widely
distributed application runtime and
that's actually quite cool because
that's something most people already
familiar with and it's a great chance to
empower people to code and produce
things they can actually use in the
modern world in their world on any
device with the browser just like they
do today so my back-end removes what I
consider a very high barrier of entry so
the white dog is also that's everyone
else so um and that barrier is high
because the simplest form of it you can
look at that a bit all to take a drink
do I have to take that down no okay the
simplest form of a web application that
a beginner might be able to deploy at
some point requires you to write HTML
CSS possibly JavaScript PHP and my
sequel that's you know the standard kind
of begin a setup people have so people
like highly paid full-time jobs just
doing the first two and that may not
seem so that to us but to most people
that might as well be actual rocket
science so just getting that set up
remotely and locally and having the to
talk to each other that will deter if
not the feed most beginners and so like
water and electricity humans usually go
the path of least resistance and in many
cases that's Google Docs and so they
just find someone else to solve their
problems instead of trying to solve than
themselves so by supporting these
complexities and reveling in our arcane
skills were helping to turn the web into
old media in a way because while we had
the patience and the will to suffer
through all this adversity of learning
these unknown and difficult things
programming was a new and exciting
mystery at least when I started with it
and the mystery is still is and the web
was uncharted and being created on the
foot and new stuff popped up all the
time and we kind of expected hardships
because everything was new and there was
a new frontier beyond which there was
only science fiction and imagination and
most people around us had no idea than
what we were doing was even possible or
existed in the world and I can
completely understand that at some point
we felt like we earned this power and
they didn't but today computing on the
web are very prevalent in our daily
social lives and the lives of most
people on earth who are somehow
connected but for many of them the web
has always been there many have never
felt that same urge to make because what
they wanted was already there when i
started with computers that's all I got
and that might be the same for many of
you you were practically required to
dive in and to try and to fail and to
try and fail again and again
again and build stuff yourself because
nothing existed and that's not the case
today for most people today the web
isn't the participatory medium it could
be yes they upload terabytes of video a
minute and tens of thousands of
Instagram pictures and years of audio
but that's content they're not making
the web they're using it that's
completely understandable because nobody
is giving the much incentive to do
anything else but that's not the point
of the web is it the web isn't just for
web developers the web is an amazing
system that can do so much for so many
and yet to most people right now it's a
photo scrapbook where you tell the
government where you're with and with
whom so we're letting one of the
greatest feats of human ingenuity
degenerate into a lifestyle magazine
that spies on you and that's sad and I
think one way to remedy this is to put
creative power in of making the way back
into the hands of the individuals which
is the point of the web all along so Tim
berners-lee at the Olympics this is for
everyone and he meant both he meant the
internet ambulant pig's blood yeah and
when he says everyone he means everyone
he doesn't just mean professionals and
corporations everyone and there are
notable precedence for efforts to put
computing power back into the hands of
amateurs so in the 1980s we got hypercar
from Apple which aimed to do exactly
that so the makers of hyper Carter said
they got programming questions from
every kind of person small business
owners school teachers ski bums taxi
drivers and it let non-programmers build
simple apps and so a lot of apps were
created that would not have been created
if apparition was left in the hands of
professional developers because many of
these apps were tailored to do exactly
what the Creator needed at that very
moment and that wouldn't have happened
if some program I had drawn up to spec
based on some marketing research for
example interestingly enough hyper talk
is apparently what inspired Brendan Eich
when writing JavaScript and I can't ask
him any more because he left already but
what's interesting is back then they
were even hardware add-ons for HyperCard
that could exchange signals with the
with external devices much like the
Arduino or the tehsil which just got
funded this month and that was ages ago
what happened I mean even before that
there was small talk 70s which was
similarly appealing to a wide range of
people but that back then nobody had the
hardware but the software existed and
that doesn't look too bad a man it looks
a tiny bit like coffeescript with his
Pleasant lack of curly braces and
semicolons and everything but the
coolest things it was easy to learn and
that thing was an integrated editor
debugger execution view thing so you ran
that and that was it you could go very
low barrier of entry so small token
HyperCard were interesting because they
made programming accessible and people
from all walks of life could actually
take advantage of these new powers of
technology that were turning up
everywhere except back then nobody had
the hardware but what's the equivalent
of that today I think its front end web
technology and JavaScript you can write
run debug and use your code in one place
in the browser you can modify the code
while it's running its platform
independent it's networked you can
distribute it via the web and anyone who
can find it can probably run it as well
and you can even fly drones and control
other hardware with it that's no limit
to what you can do with it by now that's
a very powerful tool so what should be
doing is making powerful tools
accessible and easy to set up and
quickly get started and delivered with
encouragement and enthusiasm instead of
kept to ourselves with monkish elitism
so Lenox program should be learned you
like be about play it should be about
getting things running quickly and just
seeing what happens and poking stuff I'm
not setting up servers and stuff like
that and i think--not back in technology
can be extremely helpful in this regard
so helpful in fact that one of hoodies
design goals is to make its use
attractive and intuitive to begin as a
non professionals and we came up with a
process to help us achieve this and we
call it dream code and that slide
doesn't do it justice so there's a
second slide
so when we designed the initial API for
our no back-end thing we each sat down
and wrote hypothetical apps that worked
with a fictional know back in the API
that didn't exist yet and which
reflected what we thought were the most
intuitive simple and sensible ways of
working so we didn't start with the
system's capabilities and then exposed
them to the user we started with the
users requirements and built backwards
from there because we wanted people to
have a good experience with it so
essentially dream code is user centered
design for API it and for this was
really crucial because our target
audience for Juan Pardo isn't developers
like us we are also aiming for the non
developers the non-professionals the
beginners the amateurs those who can
just barely get along with jquery that's
cool we just want to give them more
power so we've made data-driven app
development so much simpler and more
convenient it would be a huge waste not
to try and broaden the scope of the
audience that where you're dressing we
want the power simplicity and
accessibility of small talk and
hypercard in the web realm but what this
ends up meaning is that where we are
designers like we and developers we are
designers not in the way you think I
mean this I mean this differently so we
need to know the fundamentals of design
process and design thinking but not
because we need nice websites for our
projects or nicely typeset document
documentation pages but because using
what we build from finding it to
learning about it to getting it running
to working with it to failing with it to
ask them for help with it succeeding
with it all of that is user experience
we are experienced designers we shape
how people experience what we make and
it pays off to design towards that
experience because that's what Google
and Apple and Facebook do and what
developers left of themselves tend to
forget and I know this from myself as
well so how many brilliant engineering
projects are there on the web that go
under use and ignore because the
engineer at some point thought when I
didn't have a three-point getting
started guide why should anybody else I
suffered for this knowledge and so
should you and that's not a good
attitude because we're experienced
designers whether we like it or not as
programmers what we produce needs to be
designed to the users needs and how you
present it needs to be tailored to an
intended audience and that audience is
far too often the one person who wrote
the damn thing it needs to offer a good
user experience even if it's just a
snippet of code on a gist somewhere
people are going to use it and that's
just a matter of economy too because
every time a developer saves time by
leaving in something dodgy or obtuse or
not immediately obvious that time gets
wasted dozens of hundreds of times over
by the people have to try and figure it
out first and short make it easier in
even shorter don't believe in
trickle-down technology and technology
some of us share a similar philosophy to
trickle down economics which says that
if we help the people at the top somehow
everything will just trickle down and
people who aren't as savvy as we are
will somehow benefit from it but just
like trickle-down economics that doesn't
work so we we can revel in this idea of
the open web and it's all well and good
but at the moment that open web is like
an open window in the second story and
you have to bring your own ladder it's
not for everyone and I think no backing
is a great opportunity to help more
people shape the web and you you don't
have to worry about your job in your
status I mean these technologies are not
complete replacements for any tech stack
or it's not a magical solution that will
make your engineering department
disappear overnight it's just another
solution that aims to be more open and
brings a number of promising promising
benefits that are good for the web good
for us and in the end good for everyone
so to recap what is no back-end
technology that brings speed simplicity
and flexibility to web app development
not just for us but to everyone it
liberates and empowers by simplifying
development at lowering the barriers of
entry massively it's tech the chemistry
applications and kill data silos it's
tech that can make the web the platform
for entry-level general-purpose
computing and learning about code by
making getting started with the whole
thing much easier and in the end it's
also checked that requires us to think
more like product managers and designers
so we can build good experiences for
other humans which is the whole point
and all of these things are good things
it's our job to make making the web more
accessible to more people that is our
power and nobody else is going to do
this i think if we can help people
understand the web they can make the web
and if they make the web they will care
about it more and the more people care
about understand and make the web the
better we'll all be better off it'll be
thanks
you